die maske schützt uns vor infektionen
blödsinn masten helfen da gar nicht sie
ist das symbol für die krise und sie
sorgt für streit muss ft2 sein oder
reicht das selbstgebastelte modell ist
das mit dem maske tragen überhaupt
sinnvoll geregelt wir wollen uns mal ein
paar dieser zum teil nur scheinbar
gegensätzlichen einschätzungen angucken
und schauen was wirklich sache ist
[Musik]
am anfang der pandemie so im februar
märz war der allgemeine tenor masken
bringen nichts die sind viel zu groß
sodass winzig kleine coronaviren ohne
probleme der einfach durchmarschieren
ja schlimmer noch damit wiegen sich die
leute sogar in falscher sicherheit und
halten keine abstände ein was dann sogar
zu mehr infektionen führt ich selber
habe damals so was gesagt ein virus
tanzt hierdurch tango oder springt
trampolin darunter das interessiert denn
überhaupt nicht während sind so klein
die gehen dadurch und heute wir haben
die masken pflicht beim einkaufen im
restaurant in schulen beim arzt in
krankenhäusern also asche auf mein haupt
haben wir uns alle geirrt hat sich die
wissenschaft geändert ich behaupte nein
denn in wirklichkeit haben wir eine echt
babylonische begriffsverwirrung über
welche masken reden wir
und ganz wichtig über dessen schutz
reden wir schutz für den der sie trägt
oder die anderen um ihn herum
am anfang der diskussion ging es um
einfache sogenannte chirurgische masken
sowas hier die trägt der chirurg während
der op und sinn der maske ist es dass
der chirurg nicht den patienten an
steckt also dass er nicht seine
bakterien und viren in das op fällt die
wunde des patienten hinein hosted
andersrum also vom patienten zum
chirurgen hin schützt diese maske ihn
nur vor ganz groben blut und sekret
spritzern die sonst auf seinen lippen
oder in der nase landen würden
bei der frage ob solche masken denn vor
corona schützen ging es zu beginn
ständig darum ob man als träger vor den
viren geschützt ist und da lautet die
richtige antwort heute wie damals nein
zum einen weil die poren der maske viel
zu groß sind als dass sie viren die man
ja nur im elektronenmikroskop überhaupt
sichtbar machen kann aufhalten könnte
und zum anderen weil ein solcher mund
nasenschutz alles andere als dicht an
liegt selbst bei korrektem sitz gibt es
immer noch riesige freie stellen
wenn so ein corona virus so groß wäre
wie ein mensch dann passten durch so
eine kleine lücke von vielleicht fünf
millimetern über 30.000 viren
übereinander gestellt locker hindurch
als träger so einer maske kann man sich
also definitiv nicht gegen das virus
schützen
aber andersherum wird ein schuh draus
wenn ich selber infiziert bin meistens
übrigens ohne dass ich davon irgendetwas
weiß und so eine maske tragen dann
reduziere ich die anzahl der von mir
ausgestoßenen wären erheblich nicht weil
die poren der maske in diese richtung
dichter wären sondern weil die viren
nicht frei und solo in der ausatemluft
herum fliegen sondern in winzigen
kleinen tröpfchen hängen und diese
tröpfchen können zu einem guten teil in
der maske zurückgehalten werden
aber halt ein spruch ich da es gibt auch
ganz aktuell neue studien die zeigen
dass der eigenschutz selbst von solchen
ganz einfachen chirurgische mund nase
schützen doch viel besser ist
wir das bisher gedacht haben das stimmt
diese studien gibt es tatsächlich die
krux dabei ist es sind reine
laborstudien und auch nicht mit echten
viren sondern mit einer art künstlichem
aerosol und auch nicht mit menschen
sondern mit künstlichen kopf modellen da
hat sich gezeigt dass der eigenschutz
doch relativ gut ist in einzelfällen
sogar besser als der fremdschutz aber
nun muss man natürlich fragen ob das
auch in der echten welt draußen im
alltag so passiert und diese studien
fehlen doch aber wer weiß vielleicht
kriegen wir die demnächst das gilt auch
für die sogenannten community masken
also diesen stück stoff hier was wir vor
mund und nase tragen
die sind in der regel nicht viel
schlechter was das angeht
allerdings und das gilt für alle masken
nur wenn sie trocken und nicht durch
gesamt sind 100% zurückhaltend das
funktioniert also auch nicht in richtung
vom träger zu seinem gegenüber
jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen dann
macht das doch gar keinen sinn dann kann
man es auch sein lassen wenn die viren
immer noch durchkommen
und das würde sogar stimmen wenn es egal
wäre ob man nur ein paar einzelne viren
oder einen ganzen schwall davon
abbekommt es scheint aber so zu sein
dass die virus menge mit der mann
infiziert wird wesentlich darüber mit
entscheidet ob man überhaupt mit
leichten symptomen oder richtig schwer
erkrankt es klingt ja fast ein bisschen
laienhaft aber viele spricht dafür wenig
wären leichter verlauf fiel viren
schwerer verlauf und wenn jetzt die
maske zumindest einen teil der vom
träger ausgestoßenen viren zurückhalten
könnte dann kann das den entscheidenden
unterschied zwischen leichter
infektionen oder schwere erkrankungen
und sogar tod bedeuten
so ersparen die maske ist verkehrt
persönlich hätte egal welche maske
wieder aufziehen entscheidend ist der
sitz und das heißt sie muss wirklich eng
anliegen auch gerade hier im
nasenbereich welche das mit dieser
einfachen stoffmaske mal mache die hat
nämlich hier einen draht drin
den kann ich biegen und wenn der
wirklich so bleibt dann mehr kann es
hier sehen dann bleibt es in dieser form
dann sitzt die maske auch gut das ist
entscheidend damit nämlich nicht die
ganze luft außen an den kleinen lücken
vorbeikommt wenn es wirklich darum geht
dass eine maske virus dicht sein soll
dann kommen nur die viel zitierten ffp
zwei oder hier fp3 masken in frage ffp
heißt übrigens nichts anderes als
filtering face peace also filtern de
gesichtsteile die liegen zum einen dicht
an und sind so aufgebaut dass sie fast
alle viren ob nun in tröpfchen oder
nicht aufhalten können und zwar in
beiden richtungen allerdings nur wenn
sie kein ventil haben diese masken
werden ja eigentlich hergestellt und den
träger also den arzt oder die
pflegeperson vor den erregern des
erkrankten patienten zu schützen
wenn ich in afrika in der tuberkulose
klinik bin und mit hochinfektiösen
patienten zu tun habe dann trage ich so
ein ding weil es aber ziemlich
unangenehm ist in diese masken
auszuatmen hat man ein ventil eingebaut
und dieses ventil lässt die ausatemluft
nach draußen aber nichts hinein
das heißt in sachen corona aber auch
wenn der träger einer solchen schicken
ffp zwei oder drei maske mit ventil
selber infiziert ist gelangen seine
viren völlig ungehindert durch das
ventil nach außen er würde also sein
gegenüber ziemlich sicher infizieren
wenn die ft2 oder mp3 maske auch die
anderen schützen soll nicht nur mich als
träger dann darf sie kein ventil haben
eine andere frage ist ob das maske
tragen zb in gaststätten und restaurants
wirklich sinnvoll geregelt ist
wenn wir reinkommen zum tisch gehen oder
zur toilette maske auf am tisch maske ab
wir produzieren aber ein
vieltausendfache sun tröpfchen und mini
tröpfchen also aerosolen
wenn wir am tisch setzen da sind wir
viel länger wir reden laut wir trinken
wir essen was die aussprache auch nicht
trockener macht wir reden vermutlich
sogar lauter wegen der geräuschkulisse
und da wir inzwischen wissen dass die
ansteckung in einem schlecht gelüfteten
raum also kneipe über längere zeit durch
die aerosole möglich ist müssten wir
eigentlich gerade am platz maske tragen
weniger während der paar sekunden vom
eingang dorthin
das ist natürlich extrem unpraktisch
denn wir wollen ja essen und trinken ein
bisschen schwierig mit maske wenn wir
also einer erneuten schließung von
restaurants und gaststätten gerade im
herbst und winter hingehen wollen
braucht es eine andere lösung entweder
die gasträume müssen ständig intensiv
gelüftet werden mit weit offenen türen
und fenstern auch kein spaß bei regen
und fünf grad außentemperatur oder es
braucht lüftungs und filteranlagen die
in der lage sind das luftvolumen
mehrfach pro stunde auszutauschen bzw
die viren in speziellen filtersystemen
aus der raumluft abzufangen
die geräte gibt es schon forschungen
dazu laufen auf hochtouren und die
bisherigen ergebnisse sind
vielversprechend
ich bin davon überzeugt mit der
kombination aus low tech also zb
einfachen masken zum schutz der anderen
und hightech wie solchen filteranlagen
können wir die infektionszahlen deutlich
runter drücken natürlich werden sich
weiter menschen infizieren aber viel
weniger als ohne die maßnahmen
[Musik]